the House Speaker Nancy Pelosi has
guided the impeachment process to this
point but after the House vote it will
move to the Senate where Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell will effectively take
control he's adamant the Democratic
majority in the house has failed to
prove a case and argues it's not up to
the Senate to do so the Constitution
gives the sole power of impeachment to
the house if a House majority wants to
impeach a president the ball is in their
court but they have to do the work they
have to prove their case nothing nothing
in our history or our Constitution says
a house majority can pass what amounts
to a half-baked censure of resolution
and then insist that the Senate fill in
the blanks but Senate rules mean
McConnell might not actually have the
final say the procedure of the trial is
decided by a simple majority and
Republican senators are under increasing
pressure to break ranks and join
Democratic party members in seeking a
full trial with witnesses all it needs
is for Republicans to do so to decide
whether the president merits acquittal
or removal from office the Senate must
conduct a fair trial a fair trial has
witnesses a fair trial has relevant
documents as a part of the record a fair
trial seeks the truth no more no less
and new evidence has been provided by
this man Liv pond ass he'd been indicted
on a number of campaign finance charges
and is now complied with a subpoena to
hand over information connected to the
Ukraine investigation he was a close
associate of President Trump's personal
attorney Rudy Giuliani and has provided
documents that allegedly detailed
Giuliani's attempts to elicit
information from Ukraine to use against
former Vice President Joe Biden this is
a matter that lies at the heart of the
move to impeach the president the new
untested evidence will be turned over to
the Senate along with the articles of
impeachment Republican senators
already been under pressure to hear
evidence from former national security
advisor john bolton who announced
earlier he would comply with the senate
subpoena to appear the question is
whether a minimum of four Republicans
will join Democratic Party members in
defying the Senate leader and the White
House in demanding this new evidence be
heard Mike Hanna al Jazeera Washington